President Trump may issue pardons to
several Americans convicted of
committing war crimes CBS News has
learned the pardons could include a
former army green beret charged with
killing an unarmed Afghan and a former
Blackwater security contractor accused
of killing unarmed civilians David
Martin is at the Pentagon with more on
this David good morning good morning
these are all controversial cases in
which supporters of the accused have
argued that the ugly realities of war
should not be treated as crimes
my daughter was a year and a half when
he went to prison and she's six now we
drive from Texas to Oklahoma pretty much
every single week
Kristen smiles husband Paul is one of
four Blackwater security guards accused
of opening fire on Iraqi civilians in
2007 he's been in prison for four years
we're really hopeful that they'll take a
look at it and say you know what this
doesn't make sense
former army green beret Matthew
Goldstein has been charged with
premeditated murder of an unarmed Afghan
man suspected of being a bomb maker last
December the president tweeted I will be
reviewing the case of a u.s. military
hero Goldstein has admitted the killing
but his wife has conducted a very public
campaign in his defense
did your husband assassinate this
suspected bomb maker assassinate no my
husband took care of an enemy combatant
who did harm and was planning to do harm
more harm at a town hall last night
presidential candidate mayor Pete booted
edge who served as a lieutenant in the
u.s. Navy Reserve said pardoning those
who had been tried by a jury of their
peers is a mistake other US service
members in a legal proceeding determined
that they had committed crimes that is
undermining the foundation of American
moral authority at least two of the case
is now under review have not yet gone to
trial which means President Trump would
be rendering a judgement before all the
facts have been introduced as evidence
Anthony David Martin thank you David